[Music]
the fight against covert has been
immense
but it's setting back years of progress
in the battle against other diseases
the pandemic appears to be reversing the
global gains we've made in the fight
against hiv aids
tuberculosis malaria malnutrition
and maternal and child mortality the
crisis has seen a 25
decrease in diagnosis and treatment of
tb in south africa indonesia
and the philippines health officials say
it's time to fight tuberculosis again
well the disease is usually transmitted
person to person through the air
and thrives in crowds it primarily
affects the lungs
but can also occur in any other organ
the world health organization
says more than 10 million people develop
tuberculosis every year
deaths amount to about one and a half
million and sadly that's
often due to inadequate treatment
the problem at the moment is access to
health care due to lockdowns supply
chain disruptions and re-routing of
global health resources into covert
countries like mexico are paying the
price
here in dr alberto medina's private
practice they used to vaccinate babies
against tuberculosis
but since september new government rules
means they haven't been able to get a
new batch
of bcg deliveries
when you ask the people who are supposed
to deal with importing vaccines
they say a date hasn't been set yet they
told us it would arrive in january
but now some articles are saying they
won't arrive until spring
there has been a public sector shortage
of tb vaccines since the start of the
year
in 2019 the shortfall was between 76
and 96 the number of tb cases jumped
from 17
000 to 45 000
health specialists estimate that a lack
of tb vaccines
will affect between 200 000 and three
hundred thousand newborns
mexico isn't the only country where tb
is still a health threat
around 85 percent of all newly infected
people live in africa and southeast asia
with india indonesia and china
particularly affected
in mexico the vaccine shortage is mostly
down to the current government changing
the system
of how medicines are required and
distributed
but vaccine shortages began under the
previous government
this prompted the re-emergence of
diseases such as measles
which went from being almost wiped out
to 60 to 200 cases
annually
this is according to a study by the
mexican association of vaccinology
which also reported complaints against
the current shortage
we've had a shortage of some vaccines
for the last few years
we're referring to vaccines like bcg mmr
and the double vaccine
[Music]
according to dr medina young families
needn't lose hope
because the tuberculosis vaccine can be
administered during the entire first
year after birth
not just the first 10 days but the
extended vaccine shortage continues to
increase
the overall public health risk uzma khan
is medical director at ird global an
international health ngo
active in asia and africa what impact
would you say covert 19 has had on
the diagnosis and treatment of tb
so thank you ben for having me here i
um it's been a journey for tb
uh it's been devastating 2020.
we recently had data that came out and
which showed that about 20 percent
uh decline in tb diagnosis and and
treatment which is huge for when you
look at uh
infectious disease uh which has similar
you know
as a respiratory pathogen just like
covet but however whose
services were repurposed because of
covet
all the you know infrastructure was
started to get used before covet as well
whether it's lab infrastructure service
delivery
community work everything so there has
been a huge impact and
no doubt the lockdowns really affected
uh tb service delivery
so grave impact all you hear is kovakova
covert and a lot of young people i guess
would never have even heard of tb
would you say though that this setback
for tuberculosis
has been a fair tradeoff for the inroads
that have been made in the fight against
covert
not at all i think it's not a fair
tradeoff at all
uh we're going to see further decline if
we don't do something uh
you know something quickly adapt as well
if the new normal whatever that is
and i hope i just to hope that we're
going to realize how similar
the two diseases are in terms of you
know some of the case finding as well as
in other strategies and adapt tools so
that we can find synergies
and optimize you know util use you know
things like contact racing and other
uh workforce as well so that we can
tackle both diseases
so the threat to tb from covet is real
what about opportunities are there any
opportunities coming out of this all of
the research all of the focus
on the medical fields
absolutely so uh there has been a grave
impact like i mentioned but then there
has been
amazing amazing collective you know
knowledge that we have now for
infectious diseases as a result of this
global collaboration which itself is an
opportunity just learning that you can
globally collaborate whether it's for
vaccine development and having something
in a year which certainly we haven't
seen
and then there is the data that has come
out that's awesome the prevention
knowledge and dissemination of
prevention the case finding strategies
like using mobile health tools you know
drive-throughs um it's amazing to see
all of these things
also the screening having knowing that
both diseases are so similar and you can
screen it like i mentioned earlier
so there's a lot of contact tracing like
i mentioned as well not to forget
because there's so much that you can
learn in terms of what to do and what
not to do which we couldn't do with tb
because we didn't have a lot of
resources
is there more that we can learn from
covert 19 to improve tb care as well
absolutely i mean uh if service
delivery methods like there are um there
is uh
uh you can have we've been using
telehealth for tb as well
but for but kovit also you know showed
us how to use some digital health
platforms as well
and contextual because one thing that's
really important is to understand that
countries have developed some of these
tools and it's not something a global
tool that is being standardized so
there are lots of things that one can
adapt and use to local
uh you know context so yes
it was about what inequities have been
uncovered through this
covert 19 pandemic would you say
um it's a lot of inequities i mean
everywhere in infectious diseases
something that i have seen and i keep on
you know as an advocate a tb advocate i
keep on seeing
is that tb we were is a you know it's an
intimately
a disease of um you know it's an
implement disease in terms of
uh you know related to poverty and
therefore
it's all about human justice and uh
and ethics around how you treat people
with covet we've seen the same thing
although tb is a disease of the poor but
covet affected everybody
and then you saw that you know people
who were at the most vulnerable got it
you know suffered and in terms of
accessing care
uh having food support they didn't know
what social distancing means
and you know how do you do that when
you're living in crowded you know
homes so is is there a message you'd
like to get across on
this world tb day just just in a
sentence or two for us
so i think the important message is to
learn that
the important learning is around social
inequities and i would like to
talk about that because when we talk
about scientists
and researchers and people we know
everyone has of the knowledge
globally we have a lot of tools and
collective wisdom
but what we don't have is we work in
silos and i wish we would collaborate on
these kind of infectious diseases that
are borderless
and whether it's in poor countries or
whatever it should it
does help us reinforce the idea that it
shouldn't take a pandemic for us to
realize things
and we should get our collectivism on
for science as well as
become advocates for people good point
medical director at ird global thank you
very much for joining us today
thank you very much and time to hand you
over to derek williams
our science correspondent is still
cooped up in his home study looking into
your questions on covert
if one of the vaccines is less potent
could it help to take different kinds
with vaccines still scarce and in high
demand
it'll take a while for this to to really
become an issue but
but let's take a theoretical approach
for a minute say
from the perspective of next year when
at least in some places it's fair to
expect
that a wide range of vaccines
will be available more or less
on demand um but you got to look back to
look forward so
a little history first in the last few
decades the idea
of mixing and matching vaccines to to
trigger
a more powerful immune response has
gained
a lot of traction in in the field of
immunology it's been
explored in experimental hiv vaccines
for instance the concept is known
as heterologous prime boosting
and the aim is to capitalize on the fact
that different vaccines can stimulate
the immune system
in different ways so so taking more than
one kind
could help strengthen immune memory by
causing your body to make a wider
variety
of defensive cells against the disease
so mixing and matching vaccines
might prove to be a good idea in the
fight against covet 19
but it could also potentially have
harmful consequences
when it's been done in the past with
other diseases the mixing and matching
mostly took place with vaccines
that were pretty similar but but some of
the coveted vaccines approved so far
are based on very different platforms so
to rule out potential risks we'll have
to perform
controlled testing with specific
combinations
of products i think that we'll see a lot
of trials like that in the long run some
are happening already but but they'll
take time
a lot of time so for now
even in places where mixing and matching
do happen
it's only in rare circumstances and
authorities
still try to avoid it as much as
possible
you